THANKS, EVERYBODY, GOOD NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO COHEN.
OCTOBER SURPRISE, YOU HAVE HEARD
THAT TERM.
IT IS POLITICAL SLANG FOR A
DAMAGING NEW STORY THAT APPEARS
IN THE FINAL DAYS OF THE
CAMPAIGN.
THIS YEAR, WE HAD ONE, ONE OF
THE BIGGEST OCTOBER SURPRISE IS
FOR "THE NEW YORK POST," THE
OLDEST DAILY NEWSPAPER IN THIS
COUNTRY, PUBLISHED A TROVE OF
DOCUMENTS SHOWING MEMBERS OF
JOE BIDEN’S FAMILY HAVE BEEN
SELLING ACCESS TO THE AND FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT TO A NUMBER OF
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS, INCLUDING
THE COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT OF
CHINA.
NOW, THAT IS A BLOCKBUSTER.
BUT THE REST OF THE MEDIA
DECIDED TO KILL IT BEFORE YOU
COULD READ IT.
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES BANNED
THEIR USERS FROM SHARING
"THE NEW YORK POST"’S REPORTING.
OTHERS NEWS ORGANIZATION SIMPLY
IGNORED IT.
ON OCTOBER 22ND, 11 DAYS BEFORE
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION,
NATIONAL PUBLIC RADIO, THE
ORGANIZATION THAT IS LITERALLY
STATE MEDIA, FUNDED AGAINST YOUR
WILL BUY YOUR TAX DOLLARS,
ISSUED THE FOLLOWING STATEMENT:
MBR EXPLAINED THEY WOULD NOT SAY
ANYTHING NEGATIVE ABOUT THE
BIDENS COME IN HERE IS WHY,
"WE DO NOT WANT TO WASTE OUR
TIME ON STORIES THAT ARE NOT REA
STORIES.
WE DO NOT WANT TO WASTE THE
LISTENERS AND READERS TIME ON
STORIES THAT ARE JUST PURE
DISTRACTION."
YOU ARE PROBABLY THINKING, THAT
IS THE SINGLE DUMBEST, MOST
DISHONEST, HIGH-HANDED,
INFURIATINGLY ARROGANT THING I
HAVE EVER HEARD.
BUT IF YOU FEEL THAT WAY,
OBVIOUSLY YOU DON’T WATCH CNN.
ON THAT SAME DAY, OCTOBER 22ND,
AND RNC SPOKESPERSON, LIZ
HARRINGTON, MADE THE MISTAKE OF
SUBMITTING TO AN INTERVIEW WITH
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR.
HARRINGTON HAD HOPED TO TALK
ABOUT THE BIDENS BUSINESS DEALS.
AMANPOUR IS, AND WE ARE QUOTING
HERE, "CNN’S CHEAP INTERNATIONAL
ANCHOR."
HERE’S HOW IT WENT.
>> AS YOU KNOW PERFECTLY WELL, I
AM A JOURNALIST AND REPORTER AND
I FOLLOW THE FACTS, AND THERE
HAS NEVER BEEN ANY ISSUE IN
TERMS OF CORRUPTION -- NOW LET
ME ASK YOU THIS.
YESTERDAY, THE --
>> WAIT, WAIT, HOW DO THEY KNOW
THAT?
>> I AM TALKING ABOUT REPORTING
AND ANY EVIDENCE.
I AM TALKING TO YOU NOW --
>> OKAY, I WOULD LOVE --
>> NO, WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO
YOUR WORK FOR YOU.
I WANT TO ASK YOU A QUESTION.
>> IT’S A JOURNALIST’S JOB TO
FIND OUT IF THIS IS VERIFIED.
>> Tucker: AS YOU KNOW
PERFECTLY WELL, I AM A
JOURNALIST AND HE REPORTER, SAYS
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR, WHO OF
COURSE, IS NEITHER OF THOSE
THINGS.
AND NEVER HAS BEEN.
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR IS A
CELEBRITY SCRIPT READER,
HALF-WIT, WHOSE SELF-ESTEEM FAR
OUT PHASES HER ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
SHE IS ALSO, IT TURNS OUT, THE
PERSONAL FLACK FOR THE BIDEN
FAMILY INTERNATIONAL FINANCE
CORPORATION.
THAT IS NOT IN HER TWITTER BIO,
BUT IT IS PRETTY OBVIOUS.
THAT HAVE NEVER BEEN ANY ISSUES
OF CORRUPTION WITH THE BIDENS,
AMANPOUR ANNOUNCED, AS IF SHE
HADN’T JUST BEEN CONFRONTED WITH
SOME.
AND SO IT WENT, JUST LIKE THAT
COME ALONG THE ENTIRE NEWS MEDIA
UNTIL THE ELECTION.
NOW, SIX WEEKS LATER, IT IS
FINALLY SAFE TO SPEAK FREELY,
AND SO THE TRUTH IS COMING OUT.
WE NOW KNOW "THE NEW YORK POST"
WAS RIGHT ALL ALONG.
SO WAS POOR LIZ HARRINGTON OF
THE RNC.
YESTERDAY, MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
LEARNED, SOME FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME, THAT THE BIDEN FAMILY HAS
INDEED BEEN DEEPLY ENMESHED IN A
SERIES OF SLEAZY INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS DEALS THAT UNDERCUT
AMERICA’S COURT INTERESTS.
WE LEARNED THERE IS AN ACTIVE
FEDERAL CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
INTO JOE BIDEN’S SON, HUNTER,
FOR THAT VERY REASON.
WHAT IS INTERESTING IS HOW WE
FOUND THIS OUT.
THE MEDIA DIDN’T TELL US.
NEITHER DID THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
HUNTER BIDEN HAS FAR BETTER
CONNECTIONS THAN, SAY,
ROGER STONE.
HUNTER BIDEN WAS ALLOWED TO TELL
HIS OWN STORY.
HE WAS NOT ROASTED FROM BED AT
5:00 A.M. FROM DOZENS OF ARMED
PARAMILITARIES.
HE WASN’T ARRESTED IN HIS BOXER
SHORTS LIVE ON CNN.
NO, NO, NO, HE IS A PROMINENT
DEMOCRAT, SO HE WAS SPARED THOSE
SIMULATIONS.
HE SAID THE BIDEN-HARRIS
TRANSITION TEAM BROKE THE NEWS
IN A BIZARRE PRESS RELEASE THAT
INFORMED US WITH A STRAIGHT FACE
THAT JOE BIDEN WAS "DEEPLY PROUD
OF HIS BOY HUNTER," WHO BY THE
WAY MAY HAVE HAD MINOR TAX
TROUBLED THAT WILL BE CLEARED UP
THE MINUTE HIS ACCOUNT RETURNS
FROM KABUL.
THANKS FOR THE HEADS UP.
YOU MIGHT HAVE GUESSED THIS, IT
TURNS OUT THERE IS MORE.
A REPORT IN "POLITICO" TODAY
REVEALS THAT JOE BIDEN’S YOUNGER
BROTHER JIMMY IS INVOLVED, TOO.
THIS WAS A FAMILY BUSINESS, KEEP
IN MIND.
JIMMY BIDEN IS ALSO UNDER
FEDERAL CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
FOR CORRUPTION IN THE HOSPITAL
BUSINESS.
WE DON’T KNOW MORE THAN THAT,
AND WE SHOULD STRESS THAT HE IS
PRESUMED INNOCENT UNTIL PROVED
OTHERWISE BY A COURT PEERS.
HE IS NOT A FELON YET, WILL KEEP
YOU UPDATED.
NONE OF THIS COMES AS A COMPLETE
SURPRISE.
AT THE TIME, WE TALKED TO TONY
BOBULINSKI ABOUT WHAT HE SAW.
BOBULINSKI WAS A BUSINESS
PARTNER OF THE BIDENS AS THEY
TRY TO WEED WEDO MONEY FROM COMM
CHINA.
20 BY BELINSKY WAS A BUSINESSMAN
AND HE BEGAN TO WONDER WHAT THE
HELL IS GOING ON?
AND ARE INTERVIEW, BOBULINSKI
DESCRIBED ONE OF HIS INTERVIEWS
WITH BIDEN, WANTED TO KNOW WHY
THE BIDEN FAMILY WAS SO BRAZEN
ABOUT PEDDLING JOE’S INFLUENCE
TO OLIGARCHS AND ENEMIES OF
UNITED STATES.
WAS THAT NOT A RISK?
HERE’S HOW JIMMY BIDEN
RESPONDED.
>> AND I REMEMBER LOOKING AT JIM
BIDEN AND SAYING, "HOW ARE YOU
GUYS GETTING AWAY WITH THIS?
AREN’T YOU CONCERNED?"
AND HE LOOKED AT ME AND HE
LAUGHED A LITTLE BIT AND SAID,
"PLAUSIBLE DENIABILITY."
>> HE SAID THAT OUT LOUD?
>> YES, HE SAID IT DIRECTLY ON
ME, ONE ON ONE IN THE PENINSULA
HOTEL.
>> Tucker: "PLAUSIBLE
DENIABILITY."
IN YOUR BUSINESS PARTNER TELLS
YOU THAT YOUR BUSINESS STRATEGY
DENIABILITY, THAT’S NOT
REASSURING, AND IT CERTAINLY
WASN’T REASSURING TO TONY
BOBULINSKI.
WHY WOULD IT BE?
THE INDEPENDENT MEDIA WOULD NOT
BE FOOLED BY PLAUSIBLE
DENIABILITY, EITHER, THEY WOULD
DEMAND ANSWERS.
WHAT EXACTLY WERE YOU DOING?
LET’S SEE THE DOCUMENT.
BUT THEY DIDN’T.
WHEN "THE NEW YORK POST"
PUBLISHED THE OUTLINE OF THE
STORY, THE MEDIA RACE DEFINED
ITS OWN PLAUSIBLE DENIABILITY.
SOME REASON, ANY REASON NOT TO
REPORT THIS STORY.
ANY REPORTER WHO BROKE RANK AND
DECIDED TO STATE THE FACTS WAS
QUICKLY DISCIPLINED AND BROUGHT
TO HEEL.
"POLITICO"’S JAKE SHERMAN, FOR
EXAMPLE, APOLOGIZED IN PUBLIC
FOR THE CRIME OF DISCUSSING
"THE NEW YORK POST" STORY AFTER
TWITTER SUSPENDED HIM FOR
POSTING IT, FOR POSTING FACTS.
"I TWEETED A LINK TO
"THE NEW YORK POST" STORY RIGHT
AFTER A DROP YESTERDAY.
I IMMEDIATELY REACHED OUT TO THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN TO SEE IF THEY
HAD BEEN THE ANSWER.
I WISH I HAD GIVEN THE STORY A
CLOSER READ BEFORE I TWEETED
IT."
IN OTHER WORDS, "BLESS ME CNN,
FOR I HAVE SINNED."
OVER AT CBS NEWS, A KID CALLED
BO ERICKSON DID NOT GET THE MEMO
ON THE BOUNDARIES OF THE NEW
JOURNALISM, SO HE TRIED TO GET
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF TO RESPOND TO
THE STORY, AND HERE’S HOW IT
WENT.
>> MR. BIDEN, THIS STORY --
>> I KNEW YOU WOULD ASK, IT’S A
SMEAR CAMPAIGN.
IT’S RIGHT UP YOUR ALLEY, THAT’S
WHAT YOU ALWAYS ASKED.
>> Tucker: "YEAH, YOU ARE A
SMEAR MERCHANT," SAYS JOE BIDEN
TO A GUY HE HAS NEVER SEEN
BEFORE AND DOESN’T RECOGNIZE.
EVERYONE LOOKS TO THE SAME TO
JOE BIDEN, IT IS ALL KIND OF A
BLUR.
BUT HE ATTACKS BO ERICKSON OF
CBS NEWS AS A LIAR AND A
PROPAGANDIST.
WHAT IS SO INTERESTING IS NOT OF
BO ERICKSON’S COLLEAGUES IN THE
NEWS MEDIA CAME TO HIS DEFENSE.
IN FACT, SEVERAL FORMER FLACKS
FOR BARACK OBAMA MOCKED HIM ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, AND AGAIN, HIS
COLLEAGUES STAYED SILENT.
NOW, WE ARE BEING TOLD TO
PRETEND THAT NONE OF THIS EVER
HAPPENED.
IT IS ALL DOWN THE MEMORY HOLE.
IN AN ARTICLE PUBLISHED TODAY IN
"THE DAILY BEAST," PROBABLY THE
SINGLE WORST EXAMPLE OF BAD
JOURNALISM ON THE INTERNET, WE
LEARNED THAT, "EVIDENCE OF A
LARGER HUNTER BIDEN PROBE WAS
APPARENT IN THE MARKINGS ON A
SERIES OF DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
MADE PUBLIC, BUT WENT LARGELY
UNNOTICED IN THE DAYS LEADING UP
TO THE ELECTION."
"LARGELY UNNOTICED?"
WELL, OF COURSE.
THE MIDDLE OF A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, FRONT PAGE STORY ABOUT
ONE OF THE CANDIDATES DOING
BUSINESS WITH OUR MAIN GLOBAL
ENEMY, BUT SOMEHOW NOBODY
NOTICED.
JUST WEIRD, UNACCOUNTABLE, HOW
DID THAT HAPPEN?
ONE GROUP WE DID NOTICE WHERE
THE PROFESSIONAL LIARS AND OUR
SO-CALLED INTEL COMMUNITY, THE
ONES WHO WERE HAND IN GLOVE WITH
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS IN OUR
MEDIA.
SHORTLY AFTER
"THE NEW YORK POST" STORY RAN, A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE, I’LL START
PROPAGANDIST LIKE JIM CLAPPER
AND JOHN BRENNAN, PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LIED IN PUBLIC UNDER
OATH AND NEVER BEEN PUBLISHED,
THEY DENOUNCED
"THE NEW YORK POST" STORY AS
SOVIET-STYLE DISINFORMATION.
THE STORIES THEY SAID, HAD "ALL
THAT YOUR MARKS OF A RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION OPERATION."
THEY DIDN’T EXPEND WHAT THAT
MEANT.
AT THE SEALS THEY ARE, THEY
CLAPPED IN UNISON, "RUSSIA!
RUSSIA!
RUSSIA!"
>> REGURGITATING, REPEATING, AND
DISSEMINATING THIS INFORMATION
THAT HE KNOWS TO BE FABRICATED
AND SUPPLIED BY A FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE, AND
DESPITE THE WARNING, HE IS STILL
DOING IT.
>> HE HAS SAID THIS ENTIRE THING
IS OBVIOUSLY A RUSSIAN FLAT.
IT IS TO ME AND I WAS NEVER EVEN
AN AMBASSADOR.
[LAUGHS]
TELL ME WHY IT IS SO OBVIOUSLY A
RUSSIAN --
>> ROUTING FUNCTIONING AS A
RUSSIAN ASSET.
>> THOSE EMAILS WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT OUR CONNECTED TO A
ONGOING RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
EFFORT.
>> Tucker: HUH.
JUST OBVIOUSLY A RUSSIAN PLOT.
OBVIOUSLY NONE OF THESE PEOPLE
SHOULD EVER APPEAR ON TELEVISION
AGAIN, AND I DOUBT THEY WILL.
SOME ARE SAYING WE NEED TO GO
FARTHER TO FIND OUT WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
THERE ARE CALLS TONIGHT FOR A
NEW SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO
INVESTIGATE WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED
SO FAR ABOUT THE BIDEN FAMILY
BUSINESS DEALINGS ABROAD.
LET’S BE HONEST, AS MUCH AS WE
ARE ANXIOUS TO FIND OUT THE
TRUTH, AND INDEED IT IS
IMPORTANT TO COME A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR IS SOMETHING THAT NO
ONE IN THIS COUNTRY SHOULD BE
EAGER TO SEE, NO MATTER WHAT
SIDE YOU ARE ON.
WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE PAST FOUR
YEARS WHAT A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
CAN DO TO THE NORMAL FUNCTIONING
OF A GOVERNMENT.
OPEN-ENDED INVESTIGATIONS INTO
POLITICIANS ARE HALLMARKS OF
CORRUPT REGIMES AND
DICTATORSHIPS, AND MOST
AMERICANS ARE SKEPTICAL OF THOSE
KINDS OF PROBES, AND RIGHTLY SO.
BUT I MUST MEDIA START DOING ITS
JOB AND TELLING US WHAT OUR
POLITICIANS ARE UP TO, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND BILL BARR
MAY HAVE NO CHOICE.
AND IF THEY DO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR, THEY
WILL HAVE ONE UNLIKELY
SUPPORTER: JOE BIDEN HIMSELF.
LAST YEAR, JOE BIDEN WENT ON THE
RECORD CONFIRMING THAT HE WOULD
NOT INTERFERE WITH ANY JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION.
>> LOOKED, I WOULD NOT DIRECT MY
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT LIKE THIS
PRESIDENT DOES.
I’D LET THEM MAKE THEIR
INDEPENDENT ADJUSTMENT.
I WOULD NOT DICTATE WHO SHOULD
BE PROSECUTED OR WHO SHOULD BE
EXONERATED.
THAT IS NOT THE ROLE OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
FOLLOW THE LAW, LET THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT MAKE THE JUDGMENT AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT SOMEONE SHOULD
BE PROSECUTED, PERIOD.
>> Tucker: UH-HUH.
WE WILL SEE IF HE LIVES UP TO
THAT.
AT THE CURRENT PRESIDENT WAS
"DIRECTING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT FOR POLITICAL ENDS,"
HE DID NOT DO AN EFFECTIVE JOB
OF IT.
ROBERT MUELLER SPENT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, SPENT MANY YEARS
RUINING LIVES, PURELY AS A FAVOR
TO PEOPLE WHO COULD NOT BELIEVE
THAT DONALD TRUMP REALLY BEAT
HILLARY CLINTON.
THIS COUNTRY MIGHT NOT SURVIVE
ANOTHER INVESTIGATION LIKE THAT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU’VE GOT TO